someone has a dog
in their room and it is not me i've got
three of them and and uh they'll be
walking in and out so just ignore them
i i love it absolutely love it so uh
first of all congrats on your
performance in this movie
um i uh i am very curious when you hear
that tate taylor is doing a new movie
are you like yes
because it basically means you have a
role
yeah no matter how but but granted you
know i've also had
uh one line in uh i mean like that's
been our sort of
thing no matter what the part even if
it's one line i come do it just do a
cameo because
and and we we had a great record uh
going and then
a couple of things didn't coincide with
my schedule so i couldn't do it so uh we
kind of lost that
that that winning streak going but
definitely
this movie when he sent it to me and i
read it amanda adoko's
script i i i tate knew that i would want
to play this character and he he knows
me well enough to know that i do this is
that
exactly the kind of genre i love a sort
of dark
comedy and uh but but rooted in in in
this
character's real need for you know sue's
need to be
to be seen and unheard and loved and
validated and she's so starved for
attention
that she she uh it's believable when she
makes the choice that she makes
um you know so it was it did
her whole journey was just a really a
pleasure to get to
to tell to do one of the things i'm
curious
about is uh there's a scene where you're
um uh
smashing a room and destroying a
television that's not really a spoiler
this is in the
you know it's it's okay and uh i think
um
and i'm curious as an actor is there
additional pressure
what is it like to actually do that
scene where you're actually destroying
everything because
how many takes are you really allowed to
do of something like that
you're right absolutely right and you
know how you you
i couldn't wait to do it if there is
some nerve a lot of nerves behind it
because you don't want to mess up and i
had to make sure with the
set you know set crew is like now i can
break this
but i can't break this and i can hit
this but don't touch that so i
make sure i you know knew where i had to
go and hit my marks
and then it's just about having fun
destroying things which is
which is enormously fun and cathartic to
do
um i had a lot of a lot of fun doing
that i can't remember i think we
we may have only done one take of that
uh
or i think you know what hitting the tv
screen i think we had to do twice
because i it didn't hit it i didn't hit
it hard enough
but not too many takes of that but once
once i get my choreography down then
it's it's
actually it was a lot of fun to break
break [ __ ] up right
i can only imagine but but i would i
would guess that it is nerve-racking
knowing that you really
can't do this again you really gotta get
it
yep there's pressure there but but i'm a
money player
you know completely of course um
so one of the things that really
surprised me about this movie is
i thought it was going to go one way
when the movie started and it goes a
completely different way with
and there was a level of violence in
this that i was not expecting
which surprised me and i enjoyed can you
sort of talk about
this is not what maybe you might be
expecting they cut such a great trailer
together kind of gives you an idea
of what's coming because i thought god
when you start this movie if you haven't
seen the trailer
you have no idea what's coming your way
and it is kind of
uh shocking in a way some of the
the violence it's just so in it's the
the way it just
casually happens you know it's like
i had to cover my eyes a couple times um
um
to but tate did i think he did a a great
job with that i think that's part of the
tone too that it's almost done in that
way that the
um not that i don't want to say it
wasn't as stylized as
tarantino but it was uh uh
was almost casually done in a way that
made it
horrifying
i i was it was really hard for me to do
that scene with milo and she
you know something happens to her that
was i haven't worked with a lot of guns
before so
that was that was truly terrifying i
think i said to tate after that scene
was like i'm done
i'm not acting anymore i'm done that's
it
i was so upset
oh my god it made me so nervous but um
um listen i gotta go congratulations
wish you nothing but the best say
hi to the dogs